[Music]
almost heaven
West Virginia
[Music]
are you doing yeah you're very mom tells
me programs on some fancy environment
lawyer down in Cincinnati I am a
corporate defense attorney so I defend
chemical companies
well now you can defend me how many did
you lose one hundred ninety a hundred
and ninety counts you tell me nothing's
wrong here it's a small matter for a
family friend help a guy needs it a
farmer or you
that's chemicals I'm telling ya I'm
seeing documents I'd understand they're
hiding something
that chemical what if you drank it drank
it it's like saying what if I swallow
too tired
what if whatever's killing those cows is
in the drinking water
at DuPont better living through
chemistry it's our DNA you need to tell
me what the hell's going on
DuPont is knowingly poisoning 70,000
local residents for the last 40 years we
knew still you did nothing you want to
flush your career down the toilet for
some cowhand you want to take everything
that you know and turn it against an
iconic American company like an
informant isn't that right isn't that
right isn't that right yes they have all
the money all the firepower and they'll
use it I know I was one of them
our government is captive to DuPont
they're trying to force you to make me
stop he was willing to risk his job his
family for a stranger who needed his
help the system is rigged they want us
to think it'll protect us we protect us
we do
[Music]